[Music]
the rich role podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing what's happening rich
roll here
I am your host this is my podcast and we
are gonna do something a little bit
different today because things are
getting weird out there so Julie and I
have gathered here together today to do
essentially an impromptu podcast on the
subject of care and self-care in this
age of coronavirus that we find
ourselves in right now
there's a lot of fear out there there's
a lot of anxiety a lot of confusion and
uncertainty and we just felt like it was
a good moment to take a beat take stock
of where things stand and hopefully
provide a little bit of our experience
and guidance for people who are
listening who are looking to connect a
little bit more deeply and figure out
the best healthiest path forward for
themselves and for their families would
you agree and in addition we're on
lockdown we're gonna get into that in a
second but right up here up top let's
take care of a little housekeeping by
giving a shout out to our great sponsors
who help make this show possible
first and foremost they're a gun because
life is hard in general and it's getting
a little bit harder right now a lot of
us are experiencing abnormal levels of
stress throughout the day whether it's
at home with our families or at work or
as a result of physical activity all of
this stress is expressed in our bodies
and the way forward is to find a way to
relieve that stress naturally and now
while we're all sequestered you can do
it in the comfort of your home let me
introduce you to Thera GaN which is this
game-changing deep muscle massager that
I promise you is unlike anything you've
ever experienced or felt and I'm
somebody
tried a lot of different things all the
doodads out there all the foam rollers
all that kind of good stuff and I got to
tell you ther agon really is the gold
standard it uses scientifically
calibrated speed depth and power to
release the deepest muscle tension and
it gives you this kind of delicious pain
relief that we all crave after a big
workout or a long day but you don't have
to take my word for it Julie you don't
have to take my word for it you should
be on this because I know you're using
all these foam rollers so can I just say
something because you don't even know
this but I had an amazing ther Gunn
experience oh you did actually outside
our house we sure well we have them and
they look really interesting knots
important to note that this is not an
actual gun so let's just make sure it's
a massager it's like an in-depth very
very intensive massage experience and I
was over at my friend
Mel's house Mel Nahas from conscious
City guide and she actually showed it to
me and she gave me a demo and it was one
of the most amazing experiences that
I've ever had with any kind of massage
device all right well you got to get on
it because it's sitting right over there
on the other side of the room in any
event it is the preferred muscle
recovery device for over 250
professional sports teams it's used by
hundreds of thousands of folks around
the world to reduce pain to increase
your range of motion and soothe aching
muscles but believe me you just got to
try it for yourself
try faragon risk-free for 30 days by
going to thier gong calm slash rich roll
for a limited time my listeners can get
a free charging stand with their
purchase a $79 value that's tarragon
dot-com slash rich roll tarragon calm
slash rich roll we're also brought to
you today by one of my very favorite
products in the world and something that
I would highly recommend everybody
experience and check out now in this
bizarre moment that we're experiencing
and that is gravity blankets it really
is one of my most beloved possessions I
was gifted one of these quite a while
ago maybe like a year ago by Greg he
sent me one and it literally
change the game for me it has this
unbelievable ability to calm your is it
your Paris your sympathetic nervous
system right so here I can I always
confuse those two whichever one calms
you down it makes you feel safe and it
just produces the most restful sleep
that I've experienced and you guys know
I'm obsessed with getting a good night's
sleep I go to great lengths to achieve
this including sleeping in a tent so I
can't recommend this product more highly
enough here's the deal
gravity blankets are there essentially
weighted blankets they come in 15 20 and
25 pound varieties and they really are
scientifically proven as a sleep
solution meaning that they have been
established to decrease your body's
production of stress hormones helping
you fall asleep faster and stay asleep
longer and there is something so
soothing about this wait it's like the
sensation of a comfortable hug that
really puts you in almost a trance-like
state telling your body that you're safe
and producing a state of relaxation and
a deepening of my personal sleep
experience that really is game-changing
so check it out go to gravity blankets
calm use the promo code rich roll a
check out to get 20% off your purchase
that's gravity blankets calm code rich
roll to get 20% off that good night's
sleep that you've been craving and
finally on the subject of self-care
which we're going to get into in a
minute we can't overlook dental care
that's a big part of it right and dental
care really boils down to habits that's
the most important thing that means that
if you brush for two minutes twice a day
and floss regularly no matter what brand
you use then you're good there's no
secret toothpaste potion or blue tooth
toothbrush that's going to do it for you
it's all about your routine and qyp is
here to support you there electric
toothbrush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean plus my favorite part of this
whole thing is that quick delivers brush
heads automatically on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five bucks which is a great
friendly reminder of when it's time for
a refresh
and to stay committed to your oral
health and it's just a set it and forget
it kind of thing it also has a brush
cover that acts as a mirror mount and it
not only decluttered your sink but it's
also a visual cue to remember to brush
every morning and night it's the little
things right quip starts at just 25
bucks and if you go to get quick calm
rich roll today you'll get your first
refill free that's your first refill
free a GE t qu IP comm slash rich roll
Julie Pyatt how are you doing hi rich
roll thanks for inviting me on your show
it's a timely and important conversation
that we need to have I think we should
start off with just social distancing
well you know we're appropriately
distance from actually before you get
started I just wanted to interject about
the gravity blanket so you've forgotten
but the gravity blanket was my idea
that's actually found it and I was like
this is gonna be really good for you and
the thing that kind of hurts my feelings
slightly when you just did the ad is
that it's a replacement for a warm hug
and some of the community who doesn't
know us or a little bit alarmed because
this week you posted a picture of your
tent with wonderful moonrise and I
commented hope you slept well my love
and then I got a bunch of messages like
what do you mean don't you ever say you
know guys have sex is everything okay so
your comment on that from downtown yeah
you were downtown I know everybody knows
that right but anyway it was just kind
of funny so when we were on social
distancing like rich and I are already
very very masterful at social just
insane in a regular basis but um yeah so
the thing is is that you've always been
too sensitive to your not like a cuddler
during sleep so when you the good
replacement for that is the gravity
blanket because it's like a warm hug
because I still need a warm hug dude
just not for me
I don't any other human to really flush
this out though you were the first
person to say rich I think this would be
helpful to you and that was that was
quite a while before Greg gifted me the
blanket and that opinion
derived from a friend of ours who has an
autistic child and discovered that the
gravity blanket had a an incredibly
beneficial impact on calming this child
down and producing a good night's sleep
that's right you were at conclusion that
you're on the spectrum
no it's really really good I mean it's
amazing for you and your I just look at
it like you're very sensitive you're
much more sensitive than you even
acknowledge and so that kind of
experience is very nourishing for you
and very nurturing and that's why you
sleep in a tent and it's sort of like a
cocoon it's the temperature you need it
to be
it's your isolation and you just meet
you need that as the other side there's
a womb like kind of experience doing so
and I'm good with it but our marriage is
good right just for the record are we
doing yeah I think we're doing pretty
good just for people out there who like
I thought everybody knew I slept in a
tent and then I posted that on Instagram
and people were like why are you now so
our marriage is solid some love you I
love you honey and it's all good I'm so
glad and I love my tester with you and I
love your tent I'm so we're both I think
we can honestly say we are both so happy
to say goodnight to each other as we
disappear into our own spaces there is
there is no trauma learning experience
by either one of us it's just it's
really good it's independence and you
know I'm up at 3 a.m. usually meditating
doing ceremony and ritual and all kinds
of things and that doesn't work if I
share a room with someone yeah well
you're gonna wake me up and you're gonna
start lighting candles and burning
incense in the middle of the night some
kind of witchcraft something all right
well let's get to the moment the now and
I think it would be helpful to just kind
of recap our introduction to what we're
experiencing in this moment I would say
up front that I'm traditionally
relatively low-key and and and somewhat
Cavalier in the face of you know the
occasional global panic like I tend to
downplay it I was in New York
and there's like a month ago at this
point yeah that's like three weeks ago I
think three weeks ago and people were
you know pushing elevator buttons with
their elbows and a lot of people were
wearing masks in the airport and I was
looking after myself and making sure
that I was washing my hands etc but I
wasn't freaking out and that was kind of
my mo but everything changed for me like
last Thursday or Friday we're recording
this on Tuesday the 17th it's going to
go up on the 19th so about five six days
ago that all shifted when in a very
compressed period of time the NBA
postponed its games Tom and Rita Hanks
publicly announced that they had tested
positive for corona virus and I listened
to a couple podcasts I listened to Sam
Harris's conversation with Nicholas
Christakis I listened to Joe Rogan's
conversation with Michael osterholm I
read up on the internet I tried to find
the you know the best sources of
objective information that I could and
basically it completely changed my tune
on how we were navigating what was
happening and we had a conversation I
believe it was Thursday night was a
Thursday night a night where I was like
we we need to shift we got to lock
things down we made the decision to
cancel all of my podcast interviews for
the next couple weeks we called Mathis
who was downtown because she goes to
school downtown and said we want you to
come home we don't want you to go to
school on Friday and it felt a little
bit I think at that in that moment
slightly alarmist to you who's also
somebody who's pretty low-key about all
this kind of stuff in retrospect now
five days later it's clear to me that it
was the wise decision in fact we would
have been better off had we instituted
that even earlier mm-hmm at that point
yeah it was I mean it was it was
definitely I mean yeah it was a like a
clear shift on Thursday night and the
thing is that it took me a while to get
up to speed with you because we had been
sort of in this sort of one energetic of
how we're
how we were processing the information
and not going into fear and you know
we're super healthy and all that kind of
stuff and living in the moment and being
connected and doing everything that we
do and then in the evening you came in
quite agitated and you know we had some
intense conversations because you know
you were feeling like you wanted to pull
mathis out of school right then and her
school had not been closed and so I was
like well you're her dad if you want to
do that then do it
you know let's make a move so we did but
also in addition to that our son Tyler
happened to be home staying with us and
you know he's actually very you know
very researched and very informed and
you know he was feeling the same and so
what we did is we reached out to our
other son Trapper and called Mathis and
told her she wasn't going to go to
school on Friday I was on my way
downtown that evening and then you know
Jaya we just we cancelled
we just cancelled everything and just
basically said we are gonna sequester
here with our immediate family until you
know we further no further notice and
for people that don't know Tyler and
trapper are older 23 and 24 they have an
apartment in Echo Park which is near
Hollywood so they left that apartment
came here and we've been just at home
ever since yeah in the meantime we did
obviously you know go to the grocery
store and stock up I got tons of canned
food I went to the Indian market and
bought like 40 or 50 pounds of rice you
know which again was something that
seemed in the moment to be perhaps
slightly paranoid but better safe than
sorry and we've stocked up we've got
tons of food and we've been sort of
existing in this liminal space ever
since and there are pluses and minuses
to this on the plus side it's brought
our family together we're all under one
roof for you know the first time in a
while and there's something really
precious and beautiful about that you
have really engaged your cooking in a
passionate way and preparing these
amazing meals every night we set the
table we've got candles out and we have
a big family dinner and you know that's
a rarity with our kids spread out these
days yeah it's been great I'm
I'd say that there's a lot of silver
linings one of them is just being all
here together the other thing is we are
very blessed to live in a beautiful home
in the middle of nature and just to have
the time even for the younger girls to
be with the older boys it's like already
Jaya's and energy like she's already
grown up like she looks like she grew a
foot in the last week just playing with
the boys you know being with them
laughing you know fooling around the
only thing we've done is we've got out
on the trail with the dogs just once
because it's been pouring rain but yeah
it's been really great to be here and
we're all artists so you know Mathis is
doing screen printing in the garage
she'll start online classes tomorrow
you know Jaya's been in her room doing
her you know different kinds of makeup
and hairstyles and also playing with the
boys and the boys are both doing music
Tyler's getting ready to record a record
so he's preparing his first 12 roughs to
son of the producer and trappers doing
daily you know rehearsals in another
room and then you know I took out a book
that I haven't published yet it's a
memoir on homeschooling that's almost
done and realized I only have like a
couple chapters to finish and it would
be ready so I think we're all looking at
what can we do creatively what what can
we create what can we experience what
what can we make in this sort of inner
time that is uncertain but also really
precious yeah I do want to speak to our
privilege a little bit I mean we're both
self-employed and we have the ability to
work from home and do what we do you
know in the space where we live which is
what we would be doing ordinarily the
difference is nobody's coming over here
to to pod gas and I'm grateful that I
worked very hard and developed like you
know I have a huge stash of interviews
that I have to kind of moment-by-moment
figure out which ones are most
appropriate to share like I'd had a
whole set schedule and that's kind of
out the window and I'm trying to you
know ride the wave and do what feels
best you know on a day-to-day basis but
we're very lucky and that we're
that we can continue to do what we do
most people are not in our position
there's a lot of people who either have
to go to work or are being laid off or
are you know on some kind of unpaid
leave and this situation which is you
know I predict will only escalate in the
coming weeks is creating a lot of
anxiety a lot of fear and a lot of
uncertainty and that witch's brew is
contributing to behavior and mental
states mental and emotional states that
I don't think are healthy for people so
my intention in this conversation is to
provide people with a few guidelines to
help them more gracefully navigate the
uncertainty that we're experiencing and
what's to come yeah I mean and I think
it's important to note that I do have a
company where I go to work and I have
employees so I'm not I'm not only at
home I do have a lot of leeway to work
at home but we had to do a great
assessment and basically go through all
the guidelines and monitor things moment
to moment and so what we did is we
elected to scale down to a very small
crew that agreed to self quarantine
together and they're continuing the
production along with all these
heightened practices you know increased
hand-washing and you know extra changing
of uniforms and and all this kind of
stuff and then everyone on the team that
we could move virtual we did and I'm a
beginning company I'm a brand-new
company and I don't really care I mean
you know I think aside from like Amazon
or like huge huge companies I mean this
is something that is affecting
businesses it's it's affecting all of us
and so there's going to have to be some
you know some allowance or some
processes or some concessions that are
given to all of us so that we can begin
again and you know create you know
economy and be able to live and eat and
all those all those kinds of things you
know yeah well it'll be interesting to
see how that develops it is but you know
I mean listen so when you when we look
at that we have to understand that as
human beings we are resourceful and we
are resilient and as much of a crisis as
this is it is also an operation
to create a new way of being in the
world and to learn how to live more
aligned with our planet with our
spirituality with our bodies with our
neighbors with our animals and so I
think this is the work and this is maybe
where the two perspectives sort of need
to meld in the middle like we need to
know the facts we need to know what's
going on we need to understand that
sequestering now and - and one week ago
was the biggest civic duty you could
offer is to really you know and you you
came to that awareness and and shared it
and guided us into that in addition
though that cannot be the only
predominant energy that mandates the
life
so there are many things that happen in
the day and like we just talked about
all the silver linings of being home
like you know nothing in life is all
one-way and so yes we are really in a
moment of great transformation right now
and the opportunity is that without this
kind of adversity
we don't often change what we do as
humans and before we go further into
this conversation I do want to take a
moment and just recognize the suffering
of the individuals who have had the life
path where they have exited where they
have died and all those who will die so
those are all somebody's child
somebody's brother somebody's mother
somebody's friend somebody's sister
somebody's father they are not nothing
they are not just like oh well that's an
old person so they died or that's a weak
person so they died this is our
community and it's our humanity so while
we process this experience by learning
to serve love we need to never forget to
be in reverence in honor of those souls
that that was their path and when we are
in these type of experiences in my
experience as a healer as a guide as
somebody who has studied
what happens when we die my entire life
like I am focused on death always so
that I can live a meaningful life there
is a perspective at some level that all
of us have a contract and when it's the
time for exit or maybe there's multiple
exit points in a lifetime our soul mate
may mandate that we take that exit point
but to cultivate a remembrance that we
are eternal life forms this is not it
when this body dies that's not the end
this is like Earth School where we're
discovering things and evolving and we
should honor those souls in their choice
of exit or you know not at a personality
level because none of us want to choose
that at a personality level but at some
greater perspective and again I'm not
separating from the suffering of the
actual condition I'm very connected to
that however in order to transcend it we
must rise up and take a bigger vantage
point this is a special moment it is an
opportunity to you know telescope out
and canvas how we live our lives and the
state of society from 10,000 feet
I think the knee-jerk reaction is to be
in fear to mindlessly you know scroll
through the news feed and stoke those
you know dopamine hits and it's
important to be informed so that you can
make rational decisions but being in a
reactive state and a fear-based which is
essentially a fear-based state is not
productive and the path forward is to
ground yourself and achieve a level of
mindfulness so that you can respond
objectively and understand that not only
is this an opportunity but that the
extent of your suffering is related to
the extent to which you're trying to
exert control over things that you don't
have control over and it's scary to
really grok the sense that we can't
control what is happening the only
things we can control
are our behaviors our thoughts and how
we respond to others and the outside
world and the more that we can embrace
that truth and practice it that will
lead to a reduction in suffering and
we'll pull the the veil on the
opportunity that is at hand and in truth
there is something about slowing things
down and you're seeing this with people
human beings are innately creative when
they're stuck in their homes we all saw
those videos of you know people who were
sequestered in Italy who are doing
exercises on there like a group exercise
on their terrorists from some Fitness
person who is you know across the street
and singing you know together I mean
those are beautiful expressions of
humanity that are motivated by
constriction and we all hear about how
moments of hardship or moments of
constriction and restriction produce the
greatest art because it is the human
will and spirit that's being tested and
the response to that is to find a
creative way forward and in this moment
where we're compelled to slow down it
helps us take stock of what's truly
important and again the opportunity is
to realize the value in that and to
parse what is extraneous about our
fast-paced lives and make a more
conscious choice to double down and
invest in those things that are
important and to really avail yourself
of this moment for however long is it's
going to to last to engage in that
creative spark you know dust off that
book you've been working on that never
seems to get the attention it deserves
or whatever pursued it is and invest in
that yeah definitely and how about pay
the greatest reverence and honor to all
of those souls who have taken exit who
have played a role in this virus for our
own awakening how about committing
beyond the sequestered time frame how
about really looking in
side your life I'm doing that at another
level I instantly went inside and was
like how can I live more aligned and
prepare more for my death and if I was
going to I'm gonna call it graduate my
friend April calls when when someone
dies it's a graduation because you're
leaving from this realm into another
realm so if I did take my graduation
from this virus which nobody knows
I mean I'm super healthy I that's not
that's not what I feel I don't have fear
or anything like that but no one has the
crystal ball and can see every single
outcome but what I'm taking the time to
do is taking this time to really look at
if this was my last two weeks how am i
living my life what are my choices do I
want to spend that time stressed out
looking on Twitter looking on Instagram
you know grasping for control or do I
want to spend that time communing with
my spirit communing with the people that
I love you know it's probably a balance
it's probably not you know all one thing
or the other but you know you were
mentioning control and one of the issues
with this planetary realm is that all of
the systems are weighted with relevance
only in patriarchal knowledge from the
brain you know who'd and that's why
everybody's running around trying to
find a consensus like is this the right
diet is this the right political stance
is this correct is that not correct and
the thing is there is no consensus
because life is diversity and we know
from soil health that diversity is what
creates the beauty in life when we're
diverse we can be these amazing life
forms in exchange with each other and
need rich each other's life so there is
no control you are let's all be very
clear we're probably feeling it a lot
right now and that's the gift of this
experiences we're not in control the
night before or the week before a few
days before you came home you know with
this more intense information about the
need to sequester my brother was in
Nashville and I looked at the newsfeed
and there was a tornado that ripped
through downtown Nashville it could have
been him I mean my other brother was
just there my brother has his wife and
his kids and you know and there's
literally
no control he's like Julia came in the
night like nobody heard it you know my
friends are all okay but it looks like a
war zone here so the whole thing of
humanity that can be so arrogant that
can think that it has everything figured
out either scientifically or in ways of
society like our food chain like if
anybody if there are aliens which you
know you and I may disagree on on that
subject but if there are aliens let's
say there's a benevolent race Ricky yeah
I'm like how long it would take for
Julie to get the alien I have to but you
let's just mention though you were the
star trekky not not me but anyway Star
Trek so go ahead but let's just say this
just for this just for this
demonstration let's just say that you
know another race of beings came to the
planet and they saw what we were doing
with the food system with the animals I
mean it's inhumane it and we we can't
get over it because we want to fight
about who's right and who's not right
mm-hm
and it's it's inhumane I any human being
if you made them stand in the room while
they tortured and ripped these animals
to shreds it's just not humane it's not
our nature that's not who we are it's
not a judgment it's not about that
you're bad and you have to protect
yourself it's like look at what we're
doing to the planet and you know what
one of my most cherished guides
perspective on this is that this is a
gentle way it's actually a gentle way to
wake us up to let us know really what is
going to be required for us to transform
this planet we are facing climate change
we are facing all kinds of challenges
and the time to act is now there's
there's no more you know we're not in
the exploratory stage it is time to
claim your own authority go inside your
own being and find out what is true for
you I'm not saying be like me I'm saying
be like you don't be like rich be like
you we need you to be you do that work
to find out who you are
find out what you loved as a child find
out the values and ideals and ways of
living that are important to you and
then live in alignment with that
do we now think that our government is
going to give us any relevant security
or support or protection it doesn't
matter which party is in power and you
know the entire soup is rancid and you
know as a chef it's like when the
ingredients are tainted you can't just
pour salt in it and make it better and
we've come to this crisis point I mean
we're in it we're in an actual crisis
right now that you and I have never seen
in our entire lifetime yeah it's totally
unprecedented people are going to die
lots of people are gonna get sick I read
a Goldman Sachs investor synopsis that
was sent to me by a couple people from a
call that they did yesterday with
estimates that they're thinking that 50%
of Americans will will be infected and
you know some of those cases will be
mild some of them will be medium and
there will be fatalities and they're not
think about 50% they tell no no no but
50% will contract survive yeah and
there's a mild in 80 years yeah and yet
it is true that it is that this reminder
is gentle in comparison to what it could
be
it's going to be bad and we need to be
prepared for that and you know take
appropriate action and do the social
distancing and the sequestering and all
the things that we're doing to flatten
the curve at the same time it is you
know in a cosmic universal sense a
gentle reminder a gentle reminder to
wake us up and alert us that the status
quo that we take for granted and the
sort of systems that are in place are
broken and leading us towards you know
an environmental collapse and a social
and societal collapse if they're not
redressed and this is a way for us to
unify over that concept and begin to
make the changes necessary so that our
planet can survive in that human beings
can live more symbiotically on the
planet yeah and and I would say like
literally to create to create an entire
new world and in quite an entire new
experience of how we
in exchange and take care of each other
and love each other and co-create and
all of those things all of those
seemingly idealistic immature you know
idiotic things that have been literally
shut down for thousands of years on this
planet and meanwhile they've got
everybody believing that they can be the
one or two percent that makes the money
and you know it's like the there was a
children's book oh I can't remember the
name now but it's basically its story of
caterpillars that are trying to get it
to the top and they're they're literally
just crawling over each other and they
get to the top and there's nothing there
like there they were all striving to get
somewhere and you know when you do
graduate when you choose to leave your
body which I really believe is a soul
appointment I believe there are many
many options but you know you are that
is a trajectory I mean why is it that
you know some people pass and some
people don't I mean for me it's
intelligent to take a spiritual
perspective I mean how can you quantify
that you know in in concrete you know
terms you can't you know there's there's
much that is not explainable but I guess
what I'm saying is that you know this is
the time for us to live as if every day
was our last day and and and you're not
taking your bank account with you you're
not taking your credit score you're not
taking your fame your celebrity you're
not taking any of it you're just taking
your consciousness what was your
awareness and this world is so driven by
consumption it's so easy to just
medicate on Netflix and consumption and
sort of work at a certain level and all
of us are alive it's a great privilege
to be alive
we incarnated at this time for a reason
we were going to be part of the change
this is our moment this is the moment
where we get to be who we really are and
dig deep and become these beautiful
magnificent life-forms and I want to
take this opportunity to just
acknowledge all of the care workers and
all of those heroes and Shiro's that
have been you know taking care in
hospitals and the doctors and everybody
that's been working that couldn't you
know take off right
the people that are serving the food
lines workers foods you know the food
chain supply people everybody who can't
they can't stay home that's right and
it's like you know our friend Brian
O'Hara's son Connor is one of the
managers at one of the Whole Foods and
he's been in there every day like from
morning tonight super late hours and you
know this is all over the country but
but what I find and what I know we will
find is we will find our humanity
through this process and we will find
joy and beauty and creativity we never
imagined we will find a connection and a
meaning to life we never dreamed of and
it is going to be sad we are going to
lose some of our loved ones some of us
are going to exit and that is going to
be sad and we are going to grieve for
them grieve with our community but also
what I would say is don't waste their
gift honor them honor all the ones who
have raised their hand and said okay
I'll exit let's honor them by not
wasting this opportunity we are the ones
we've been waiting for it's us it's not
a government it's not a system it's not
a club it's not a celebrity it's none of
those things it's us all of us in our
own unique individual life prints not
another one of us in the entire
multiverse we have so much power and
creativity and beauty that is inherent
within ourselves if we can only be
courageous enough to become our own
Authority and understand that it's you
it's you that is going to be the change
one of the most potent aspects of this
experience is this palpable sense of
unity you know even when we're out on
the trail and you see one or two other
people out there there's kind of there's
it there's a you know an unspoken
acknowledgment that we're all sharing a
particular experience and that you know
coalesce as human
you know and I think there's something
really powerful about that if it can be
channeled in the right direction oh yeah
totally and you know that's the beauty
of this type of learning experience is
that it doesn't discriminate you know
it's it literally you know you can't
escape it from your title or your
economic State or anything it's
literally affecting all of us it's
affecting all of us and you know it is a
virus as as we are a sort of virus to
the earth the way that we interact with
her yeah there was an article that was
sent to me by a couple people including
Howie Nordstrom sup Howie
hi I think that article was entitled
something like it's not a virus it's the
medication it just flipped the
perspective on it as you know a way of
looking at what's happening as you know
a possible you know cell for the planet
ultimately in the long run and I don't
want to minimize you know what people
are enduring right now but from you know
a global perspective you know it's a way
of recalibrating how we live so that we
can you know forge a better way yeah
absolutely and you know it's all
perspective and that's it that's the
thing that I want to really encourage
people is the work in this moment it
takes maturity and spiritual awareness
to make a decision to not loop with the
negativity your mind and your ego will
want to agree with it oh yeah you know
this could cause a financial collapse
you know and your ego feels yeah this is
true because I'm seeing all those signs
but we have to remember that we are
creating a reality in every perspective
we choose and so that article that Howie
shared I don't know if he wrote it or
somebody else wrote it but that is the
awareness that we want we need to flip
the perspective so just a basic example
from our life when we went through
financial collapse I flipped the
perspective to this is my spiritual
alchemical moment I'm not a deadbeat I'm
in my sacred moment so again applying
that to this experience we are not going
to be annihilated
this is our sacred moment it's our
wake-up call and this is the moment that
we get to rise up and be everything that
we've ever been we may go through some
experiences that don't look safe to us
or don't look like what we experienced
for instance when we went through our
financial collapse we had no health
insurance I had days where I was down to
one potato we learned through that
experience that something always creates
something always arises something always
appears and some of us are going to have
to learn the very sacred lesson of being
able to receive help from another
because in this Western society or
modern society you know we've been so
isolated and so you know self determined
that we have learned unconsciously that
it is shameful to receive help from
someone else and when you have been
reduced to your knees in such a way you
will graciously and gratefully accept
the help of someone else and that is a
it's a flip of what you're usually used
to so it is all perspective it's
entirely perspective and this is what
I've been talking about is that there
are all kinds of people talking about
all the problems at nauseam all the time
and not just in this crisis but even
before it last time I was on your
podcast we need to understand that we
are creating our experience
moment-to-moment and that doesn't mean
that you put your head in the sand and
you don't know what's going on yes
get the facts kind of know what the
ground is keep yourself safe follow all
the protocol do not deny what is
happening this is a very severe very
real pandemic and and even with that
information you can flip that
perspective mhm and you can choose to
serve that and to be in love and to be
in creativity and hopefulness and you
know it's a choice to believe in
humanity it's a choice and you can make
that choice and celebrate it it's a
choice that's both intellectual and
emotional and I think it's easier for
people to wrap their heads around making
that choice you know from their brains
from their
taking brains but emotionally trying to
quell the you know pangs of anxiety that
people are feeling that that are you
know rooted in legitimate concerns I
think is a you know when I when I put
out on social media like what do you
want us to talk about I mean that was
overwhelmingly the largest theme which
is how do I you know deal with the
anxiety and the uncertainty of this
moment you know on a day-to-day like
practical basis well you know how you
deal with it as you develop your
spiritual connection and you understand
that the spiritual connection is the
really only important relationship in
your entire life it is first it is
second third fourth it is when you have
a spiritual connection you you
understand that life has a mandala life
has a plan life is an unfolding that it
is not up to you you know at this level
of human to to be controlling everything
with your thoughts or you know reading
the news or trusting sources outside of
yourself you have to trust yourself you
have to develop this alignment and that
comes through meditation it comes from
just really making the decision and
saying you know what I'm living in this
human life I'm gonna trust myself I'm
gonna nourish myself and nurture myself
every single day what do I need what is
the best for me what would be the most
supportive for me the all of these kinds
of things and the other thing that I do
want to mention and it's very very
important that we bring in the mother
energy the female energy into the
conversation not conversation experience
of this issue it is the tendency of a
male society to want to overanalyze all
the tactics and then make fun of the
feminine for wanting to do a prayer or
wanted to do meditation or being able to
hold this loving nourishing capacity I
mean we must understand that both
energies are part of life it is not
going to be solved by only intellectual
facts and figures that is not going to
be the way the way is through connection
into the
great mother the great cosmic mother
which is really the greatest force that
is over all of us we need both we need a
balance of both I mean we need to be
able to test people we need to be able
to provide people with adequate medical
care like all of the you know
infrastructure and all of that is
important which you know is probably it
falls on the masculine side but we need
a balance of both and you're right our
culture is tipped towards the masculine
a huge way yeah I would say granting you
that yeah well you should I mean it's
it's it's drastically that way and in
the moment where you're facing your
death you're not going to be checking
facts on Twitter you're going to be
wanting that mother's embrace that
connection the faith the magic the
creativity that connects you with that
force that you know is greater than your
own being 1% 100% so it begins with
acceptance rather than grinding against
reality surrendering to what is like
just basically being in an opened armed
like open you know embrace of the
situation that we find ourselves in
suffering comes when you're trying to
deny that or basically you know be
resentful or frustrated at the truth of
the circumstances that we find ourselves
in and the more you can do that the more
peace you will find for yourself and
whether that's through meditation
practices or whatever protocol that you
adopt the more mindful and grounded in
the moment you can be then the better
position you're in to be responsive from
your highest self as opposed to reactive
from the more reptilian you know brain
aspects of who we are yeah it is and you
know there's ways of course you're gonna
wash your hands a lot you're gonna self
quarantine you're going to eat as
healthy foods as you can find you know
of course turmeric fresh ginger any kind
of spirulina any kind of just fresh
fruits how about we just eat an orange
just peel it and eat it don't go to the
breads don't go to a bunch of sweets
don't eat a lot of sugar don't binge on
donuts right
now you need your immune system strong
so eat as much Whole Foods whole leafy
greens fresh vegetables organic if you
can find it eat as much Whole Foods as
possible at least you know for the the
beginning of this you know we may get
into a situation where we have to turn
to can things and this this is fine but
I'm just saying really nourish your
immune system so you want to get sleep
you want to eat healthy Whole Foods you
want to be in the Sun if you can safely
get outside spend time in the Sun if you
can do an open eye meditation on the Sun
right when it's rising if you can see
the Sun actually pop over the horizon
you can actually gaze at that and get
tremendous healing frequency if it rises
to a 45-degree angle you have to stop
looking at it because then it can become
dangerous but the Sun is a very powerful
source of energy we need to acknowledge
it go out and spend time in it training
it like rich does another thing you
could do is take salt baths make sure
that you're getting in bed before you're
tired don't watch a bunch of scary
movies and you know panic and citing
information movies or news articles move
your body develop a nourishing self talk
with your body about how grateful you
are for this body how healthy this body
is and even if you develop some symptoms
keep nourishing your body and know that
you're going to recover you're going to
heal it is a perspective right if you go
down and start entertaining thoughts of
doom and gloom you're going to fuel that
trajectory so this is where the work
comes in I am healthy I am whole I am
well and with your permission rich I
would like to do a meditation and a
healing for everybody who is listening
today can we do that at the end when
we're done oh yeah I thought it was the
end no we're not done yeah okay listen
you know the trail running getting out I
got on my bike the other day like that's
been the saving grace for me and we live
in a place where it
possible for me to be able to do that to
be out in nature you know that's
complete social distancing is I don't
see any other human beings that we on
the running obviously if you can do that
you know lean into that another thing
that came up with you know people
commenting on what they wanted us to
talk about is disappointment over things
getting canceled people who are training
for big races the races get canceled our
friend andrew is planning on getting
married in May that's very much in
question and it's probably not gonna
happen then a lot of that is going on as
well and I think that's a different
flavor of acceptance and surrender as
the path forward it's just this is
what's happening and rather than rally
against it and be angry or frustrated or
sad or resentful just embrace it accept
it this is something that's affecting
all of us for the athletes out there who
are disappointed that the race is being
canceled understand that the race really
isn't what it's about the race is an
excuse for you to take care of yourself
on a daily basis to prepare your body
and your mind and your soul to endure
something difficult and just because a
race is taken off a calendar that
doesn't mean that you need to deprive
yourself of that experience yeah I mean
I think the perspective is quite
important here I mean you know we have
to be grownups we have to understand
what we're facing right yeah I mean this
is not about marathons cancel yeah so
we're in a global panic
unprecedented our lifetime you could be
not alive where people could not be
alive so I think we have to trust in the
divine timing of this once again I want
to mention again that in my feeling this
is it is actually a gentle it's it's
it's not going to go to the depths of
the greatest naysayers that are
predicting Armageddon and these type of
things these are programs that are used
to incite fear panic people make them
feel helpless so we need to remember
once again this is going to cycle
through we're all in this together and
the more we can take care of ourselves
and take care of each other's through
checking in virtue
and you know just being together and
knowing that together we'll get through
this I think the better I did have I'm
actually somebody also message me and
wanted me to talk about how to handle
family members that don't have the same
perspective that you have and so I think
this for Katherine Katherine thanks for
messaging me sweetheart
so you know again I think this is a
moment
for many many reasons as I said you know
owning your own authority you know you
can inform as much as you can you know
on social media with your family let
them know send them the articles I had
an experience as well with someone in my
family who just wasn't informed the way
that I was and I sent them some
information for their own you know
review and at the end of the day you
don't have control over another human
being and so what I would rather you do
rather than have your energy and another
Hugh being however we do have control of
our children we exerted that over our
teenager that's a whole other thing we
could kind of talk about a little bit
because there's probably a lot of
parents listening right now who have
teenagers and for me the most
challenging part has been dealing with
vicissitudes a sixteen year old girl who
you know it's not happy about her social
calendar getting truncated it's
unbelievable the amount of energy that
goes into that and and it's tested me to
my limits like trying to figure out how
to dance around that yeah I just have to
roll you're much better at it's Who I am
she's my wave I just surf her but ya
know she's she's a she's actually
already conformed there's been
conformity happening in the last two
days and we were get we were giggling
saying like the silver lining is going
to be like the transformation of you
know certain personalities into more
expanded healthy creative expression so
to say that's like first there's anger
and then there's pushback and then
there's acceptance there's grief or you
know it's like she's going through those
stages right now I think we're getting
into a better place no no no she's
actually she's been screen-printing in
the garage she's done a bunch of a bunch
of beautiful artistic work and anyway
she begins her online classes tomorrow
so it's fine but yeah it was it's kind
of been a source of comedy
we've we've joked a lot about it with
the kids but anyway I didn't want to say
to Catherine's question is you know you
can't control their people right I mean
we've we've all experienced that in our
families with those of us that are
eating plant-based you know it just
seems so obvious like why isn't
everybody you just stopped already and
yet it's still going on I mean it's
almost like it takes something of this
severity to really catalyze you know
real change at a deep level so what I
would say is again as I advise with rich
in my relationship it's like really
after you've informed and shared your
heart in neutral loving compassion take
that magnifying glass back on your own
heart and I would start really working
on being a masterful life form at the
point of your death
that is really why we're all here to
learn how to die to learn how to make
that transition knowing that we are
eternal life forms that the life doesn't
go out and that we will continue in
different forms in different places so
yeah I think we have to again contain
our energy and decide where you want to
direct that energy and you certainly
don't want it to be siphoned off by
individuals who may not choose your path
and also they may end up being perfectly
fine making all those choices that they
made that are contrary to every choice
that you made so it's okay I would just
sort of let go inform and let go mm-hmm
another big thing is sober people who
now you know are faced with the prospect
of not being able to go to meetings
there's a lot of you know concern about
relapse drug and alcohol use in the home
things like that of this nature while
people are kind of you know living on
top of each other in a way that maybe
they're not used to and the social
dynamics that come with that and to that
I would say more and more meetings are
going virtual I mean if I don't know if
you can buy stock and zoom but that
would probably be a good bet right now I
know that meetings in my area or I'm
getting links from friends they're
resorting to zoom meetings so if you
participate in a 12-step program and
you're listening maybe you know be the
captain of that kind of change there's
also plenty
of online resources and tons of you know
meetings that are in audio form online
and what I'm going to do is put together
a resource list that I'll put in the
show notes to this podcast with the best
information that I can compiled on that
subject and also on the subject of you
know if you are on Twitter who are the
better people to follow who can give you
objective points of view and take all
the partisanship out of this and other
types of resources that I think would be
you know why isn't prudent to follow if
you do make the choice to engage it with
social media on this issue that's great
that's really good and also for any of
you that have interest to go deeper with
me into the spiritual cosmic view of
what's going on in the planet I'm doing
to online virtual events with conscious
City guide you can check out my
Instagram feed but I'm going to be
teaching a yoga class that actually
embodies you and your own life print so
that you can be your own authority and
really live embodied in the unique
Divine Design in which you were created
I'm also going to be doing sort of a
discourse which I will present the
cosmic view of what's happening things
that are happening behind the scenes by
beings that are not informed that are
helping humanity so we have to remember
there's all kinds of unseen things that
are part of our life and those life
forms are helping us helping humanity
and there is so much love and so much
help for us as a species and they're
really really hoping that we get our
[ __ ] together and that we evolve into a
brighter way yeah I'm thinking about
doing a daily Instagram live kind of
thing I think a lot of people are doing
that because there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of programming out there
so why not grow my hat in the ring I
don't know I'll give it a try
know it listen it's really important and
the other thing is we're gonna have to
pivot ah online we want people to stay
you know healthy in their offerings and
what they're doing in the content so and
it's a it's an opportunity to answer
questions directly and get more granular
on some lifestyle practices that you
know we've availed ourselves of that I
think would be helpful yeah definitely
and while we're on that subject I do
want to mention our plant power meal
planner
this is our meal plug I just know it's
important and it's under two dollars a
week so it's very very accessible but if
you guys aren't using it already it is a
seamless amazing platform that basically
just customizes all your recipes I'm
sure you've heard rich you know add it
before here but I'm just telling you
from my heart the team at SRI Moo has
been infusing we've been infusing it
with you know new fresh recipes and it's
just an amazing it's an amazing offering
I mean what can you get for under $2 a
week that has that level of service and
you can customize it you can put in what
you're allergic to what you don't like -
how many people what you don't like to
eat how many people you're cooking for
and maybe in these times of like really
trying to decide what to cook it might
be helpful to you so anyway I just
wanted to mention that as well and you
can find that at Rich's site ritual
dot-com yeah just meals dot rich roll
com I mean it's it's basically an
unlimited supply of delicious
plant-based recipes and if you're in a
metropolitan area there's a good chance
that it integrates with grocery delivery
so in this time of sequestration you
could prepare these new recipes to do
something fun and creative in your home
as well and have everything that you
need to prepare them just basically
deliver to your door which is pretty
cool yeah yesterday I actually found I
had two coconuts in the fridge that I
just hadn't I hadn't taken the time to
open them up and and there I was with a
lot of time and so I opened them up and
took the meat out and sat down on the
table and actually had a half an hour to
take all the brown bits off and just it
was a moment of presence of cooking
usually I'm racing to like photograph
five recipes or you know shoot a bunch
of food and it's never like with that
kind of experience and so it was really
beautiful and also I had a first
yesterday and that's that rich made me a
healthy drink he actually made me first
I think it's the first No yeah honey
I think so he made me an orange how can
that be because you're not really
tumeric yeah or ginger carrot turmeric
yeah yeah it was good it wasn't that
good but I drank it it wasn't I told
Malthus I was like like your dad made me
a healthy drink and I go it doesn't
taste good but I'm gonna drink it
because I know how much love there isn't
it I never make these things with tasted
mine
they just I'm like this is what I need
right now this is what a manager it's
get down to just always leave the taste
for you it's but it is you know again to
kind of bring it back to the beginning a
moment where we can really take the time
to you know prepare beautiful meals for
our families while we're cohabitating in
this way and to create you know ceremony
and ritual out of that because you know
when you've raised kids and then those
kids get older and they leave the house
it's only then that you realize how
precious those mealtimes are with
everybody yeah I would say like the
house being just filthy dirty and and
then all of a sudden the house is clean
and I was like oh that clean house is
overrated because we're all the kids I
see it's been raining like crazy the
house is super dirty the dogs come in
with mud all over them and jump on the
couches and you know just is what it is
right now super awesome all right so
let's wrap this up drink a lot of water
eat healthy plant-based meals as much as
you can get tons of sleep try to
exercise outdoors if you can if that's
available to you get outdoors even if
for just a walk expose yourself to the
Sun call your friends zoom them tell
them you love them this is a moment
where we're all trying to connect and we
need to get creative with how we do that
and enjoy the company that you're
keeping in your sequestration and above
all meditate hmm that is the most
important thing so as you're getting
more sleep get up early in the morning
before the Sun rises sit in silence
connect feel yourself as a greater being
feel the energetic that you are that is
beyond your human body and start to
remember yourself as a divine organism
you're here in a life
is blessed such a privilege to be alive
and what are the ways that we can
express our own unique divine design in
ways that are more expanded more
meaningful more powerful there's nobody
coming here to save us
we are the ones we've been waiting for
it's not one person it's a diversity of
beautiful precious creative
extraordinary life life doesn't make
mistakes and so let's take this
opportunity to truly truly remember our
divinity and our birthright which is to
be merged with the eternal essence of
what it means to be a divine human this
is just one play it's just one role that
you're going to experience in all of
your existences in all of the places
where you dwell across the multiverse
let's not waste it let's make the most
of it let's rise up and be all that we
can be and let's be unified and not
judge and tear each other down let's
look for all the ways that we're the
same let's look for all the ways that we
connect so can I do the meditation now
yeah I wasn't sure whether that was the
meditation or not okay that was just the
monologue that precedes the minute okay
I was just creating the energetic field
okay but now you know I'm kidding it's
fine alright go ahead
okay so I'm gonna ask you to close your
eyes if you feel comfortable of course
if you're driving don't close your eyes
okay stay with your awareness on the
road and know you can return to this and
so in healing practices we understand
that there is no space and time so
wherever you are rich and I are
connected with you directly and wherever
all the listeners are we are all
connected in this energetic field and so
I'm just going to open the field and
sacred service to the law of one the law
of one is the unified field where we are
not separate we are connected resonant
and eternally thriving and as I open the
field I ask for all it is needed
necessary for the highest exchange which
with each individual person as is in
alignment with their highest directive
beloved future selves nature spirits
guides teams from the cosmic universe we
call you present now to assist us during
this great time of transformation we ask
for nourishment and comfort and
compassion around all of those who are
suffering both animals humans plants and
our mother earth and beloved teams as we
endeavor to walk through this journey
please lead us direct us and guide us to
the highest expression in order of
priority that is in the highest
alignment for each individual we
understand the beauty in diversity we
understand the presence in love we
understand and we welcome to experience
the power of the human heart
please open all channels of light to
connect us with each other in ways that
cannot be broken please open all
channels of communication in ways we can
co-create nourish and nurture each other
please open all channels of light to
remind us that we are the ones we've
been waiting for and for all our beloved
human tribe who have graduated and who
will graduate throughout this experience
we ask that they
safe passage and that they be connected
to the Trinity gates and they be cared
for and taken to their highest directive
in the universe and for this and so much
more we offer our gratitude our love and
our commitment we are unified we are
together and we are with each other and
so it is beautiful for people that are
listening who might think that Julie
just read that off a piece of paper she
was sitting across me with her eyes
closed just channeling it you guys are
super special to us you've made our life
makes me cry it's a joy
thanks for being with us appreciate you
guys I love you I love that I get to do
this and we're gonna do it again we're
gonna be back to our regular programming
we'll be back tomorrow yeah back
tomorrow with another yeah maybe well we
should actually I should come to the
tent and sleep with you one night dude
doing insta live we'll see about that we
will be back here in a couple days with
regular programming I think it's
important to you know kind of maintain
the integrity of the show as it as it
you know exists but I want to be
adaptable and spontaneous to be able to
pop in and do maybe a you know a few
more shows than usual on the subject
matter to kind of deal with what's
happening in current events so you can
look forward to that if you're digging
on Julie you can find our at Srimati on
Twitter and Instagram Instagram is our
jam you can check out her delicious
amazing plant-based cheese's at SRI
muqaam sr IMU comm we talked a little
bit about that in more detail next time
and I think I will try out some
Instagram lies so you can find me on
instagram at rich roll awesome and I'll
be I'll be up with a water tiger call
next week if you want to join my
spiritual community you can find that at
julie payette calm and your podcast and
my podcast for the life of me I started
again so yeah it's true I'll be putting
podcasts up and just offering techniques
water tiger is a monthly call a monthly
QA and a monthly topic presented and I
have a bunch of techniques similar to
the one that I just did for different
purposes as we navigate this human
trauma not just this human drama but
human trauma from all kinds of things
ancestral things and histories and many
many things but anyway it's a beautiful
time and there's so much support for us
here and so take care of yourself and
each other take care stay true
[Music]